what a week they spin first here in UK
my house gets flooded pure panic for the
past couple days and then my place in
Japan was robbed and they took all our
stuff epic I need to look at some place
images on reddit to know the whole world
isn't just rotten thank you this is the
Blessed images sub ready draw your
favorite and tender character in this
and nothing else
well that's freaking adorable okay all
right what is this bless grandma
nineteen year old grandma guesses
Pokemon names I'll calm him Hamilton why
why am I do I not get it does that dumb
grandma not know it's char man there all
right this is not working for me that
much so far thinking about how Dutch
police arrested a bird for taking part
in a robbery but put it in a jail cell
with bread and water when the media
reported on it they put a little black
bar over the face to protect its eyes
what happened here this is a curse image
he's been framed by President Barack
Obama he's a nurse saying it's Takashi
six nine spurt this is very confusing
imagery so far my cat found an
unattended cracker and brought it to me
so I could hold the further where was
she
that's so cute oh this is Jared you will
see him once and never again say hi to
Jared bye Jared I guess I'll never see
you Dan this looks like it cinnamon
toast Ken when I get bigger I'm going to
be my dad's partner and catch bad guy
and burglar al can't stop hugging the
man who saved her after car accident
what why are all animals so blessed word
yeah I'm a bit confused about the
details behind this where do they all
learn how to drive yeah
clearly the L doesn't drive very well at
least at least we know that at least we
know that thank you man
you saved my life armed I'd be in the
ground before once for you may move to
Japan met my neighbor I can't speak
English thank you for the present
my name is Hiroshi Yamashita I am 52
years old I divorced and I live alone
you can use it if you like I'm stuffed
and toilet paper
do you have Navy yes no please tell me
your child's name thank you for your
friend operation friend up at raised yet
he got this because he gave a present
when I go to Japan I have to I'll make
sure to give a gift to everyone
all my neighbor's that's great I think
it's someone has a crush on my Christmas
light decoration Oh what
it's so cute mm-hmm there's a dog in
this class why does a dog look so
adorable
don't tell anyone may I'm trying to
become a physicist come on man I need to
study a lot how in America you can have
an emotional support dog actually it
won't fly in UK or anywhere in Europe
but only in America yeah it's emotional
support they need it I'm not letting
anyone that has that I think it's great
by the way but I wish we could get away
with it not old enough to watch prawn
but old enough to watch my planet get
freaked oh your planet
I read planet and I read parents Oh No
ah what is it cursed 100% cursed I've
read that wrong what is this
my dog is a hero companion worker he's a
psychic
oh yeah I've seen this early childish
can being a gig that's there he has
undergone zero design changes since
Yoshi's Story this is because he is
without flaw has the other ones changed
I mean it is a classic figure eight
figure is the belt is brighter but okay
I've been informed that the meme cat is
named smudge and he has an extensive
history of being a goblet what what
I not know this that one is so good - oh
my sister's husky ran out of ink while
giving birth oh my god what are they
stacked up this is so weird are they
against the wall what am I looking at
how tall this a tower of husky go how
tall I just face what my dog in my cat
oh my god the cat looks so scary
what is that ungodly creature see that's
why we need these face filters and face
swaps for animals they always make them
for people I don't care about me what's
up or other people what's up with
capybaras capybaras chilling with other
animals just chilling with a gator
that's normal right I feel like anyone
that can chill with cats and alligators
is one badass [ __ ] you might
even be so chill you're friends with an
alligator even the alligator looks happy
missing dog returns home with new dog
and goat friend oh my god big goat
friend I don't know about the goat
friend to be it's like the psychopath
that move into your house look it's my
friend we're friends like oh it is not
your friend
come on rats can be taught to play hide
and seek and they squeal with joy when
they win scientists have found what when
they win when they don't find you or
what hide and squeak I'm gonna see that
why is if not video that then stinky
scientists do your job I don't care
about curing diseases
find the rat screen accidentally washed
a piece of Halloween confetti down the
sink and I'm afraid to say the plughole
is now very haunted that's actually
terrifying why sir coyote on a bus
because they can't drive that's fair
that's actually fair today in art class
our teacher was absent and our
substitute was one of the animators for
courage to cover lead on that is so cool
one of my favorite cartoons throwback
Thursday to Clifford's first Halloween
yeah I don't know this this stuff
doesn't do it for me I'm not gonna lie
Thanksgiving dinner is
and my house hope to see you all who is
those your grandma grandma can I have a
picture of who you lo yes Here I am at
work you're not my grandma can I still
get a plate though of course you can
that's what grandma's do feed everyone
they were went to the pumpkin patch
that's so sweet
wait they became friends for years
Oh for us fine look at that log go on
take a gander turn it over and you might
find a friendly salamander really home
don't know I love this picture his
health bar is enormous
cowboy advice be rooting be tootin and
by god be shooting but most of all be
kind that's terrible advice
I work in an animation studio with some
of the best artists I've ever met and
this is the pumpkin carving cut Dez
dancer day yeah I especially appreciate
that
the non-horizontal caught that's very
great this guy dresses up and costs him
at the gym to take the attention away
from his overweight friend who was
embarrassed to go to the gym that is
actually really sweet let me just say no
reason to be embarrassed to go to the
gym like whatever your size is the point
of being at a gym is to to work out at
least you're you're doing something
right you can't like there's no reason
to be a mess go to the gym should go to
the gym wait what the hell is Satan
doing at a blessed subreddit get out of
here Satan I don't need you right now
animals aren't as smart as humans
animals enormous lion terrifies
photographer with loud roar than smiles
at him got you [ __ ] I told my grandma
she look cute today and she said she
wanted to match her favorite chair lol
gramma flash wait where is she oh my god
can't see what this is one of those
posts that is fake and it's still the
highest gotta report this to the
authorities
frozen Hispanic voted best burger in
town by some guy who likes burgers
nice that's that's the most legit review
you can ever get whatever is steamed
rating you could get it doesn't matter
as long as some guy says it our local
Mexican restaurant used to be Chinese
restaurant instead of painting over
Amaral they just put some rarest on the
process that's the finest piece of
cultural appropriation I have ever seen
so cute oh my god what this little guy
jumped onto our boat stroll into the
cabin and made himself at home why do we
eat animals they are so thank you I know
people don't eat seals but I'm saying
what early this year a random number I
don't recognize started sending me
pictures of toads European a common
spadefoot toad true true red American
total it thank you mr. Ito Dukey what's
the time two days after Fowler's toad
thank you
brand your frog aka egg pablor bunk yes
does he play banjo better his own calls
sound like plucking a banjo string like
bunk bunk for Yoshi when he eats an
apple what is that what Yoshi sounds
like that what oh my god incredible okay
I have to know who are you I send you
toads I send you toads this is all you
need to know this is just as good how do
you get my number I think I just had it
I knew what number to send best valid
okay I will continue to save your number
and just enjoy toad content bunk bunk
banjo frog I got to look that up what I
sent you toads bug bunk
rest in peace Oh little sister draws
peppers because they look you that's
wholesome okay actually no little sister
is racist dog whistle of course there's
no other there's no nuance I literally
never do this so it shows how important
it is to me my favorite person in the
world is cat is very ill and right now
it needs a blood transfusion any
donations would mean the world to me
whoever just donated 666 yours alleged I
love you so much is so awesome
you think cats will never not be funny
[Laughter]
that's so cute
you think this one will get a lot of
likes on Instagram maybe I should stick
my tongue out a bit more oh god Florida
man Florida man slaps a woman for
smoking while she's Florida man yeah
it's like if you're not willing to give
up those sacrifices for a child and
don't have a child please father sells
ultra-rare UVO collection worth 20,000
for daughter's education
what is that how much blue-eyes White
Dragon cost I think it is a crazy
expensive isn't it what excuse me okay
damn that's cool that's really cool UPS
has a page where the drivers can post
about all the dogs they meet on the job
that is so cute I wouldn't find that oh
beware of the dog I am in danger help me
help me way what Oh spongebob robbing a
bank
spongebob robbing a been 10th
anniversary remaster Wow in art is alive
and well everyone we're safe dad I
located in the balls epic I wonder what
was in there passed out at a London bus
stop woke up to this go with him he
wants to show you see everyone has
amazing interaction with animal last
time I saw Fox it took a she get in my
backyard like it's not fair I'm a sneaky
Fox sneaked in your house sat on your
couch ate your pasta maiden you reddit
account enough photo your post huh what
thank you folks
Oh what that's so nice I did not expect
that
Wow I'm so glad everyone liked the suit
I wore it's Lily with Marge say we went
to so many places she took all this time
she looks amazing obviously she took so
much time she designed it she made
revisions a little
went into the shop picked one tried it
once
[Laughter]
holy sh t that is amazing
bless Godzilla literally Godzilla why do
you eat pizza like this
answer me coward I need answers
seriously what the hell this man is
running your country people were mad at
me for eating the pizza inside out and
your president this is the most
offensive thing I have ever heard anyone
what I know there was a blank wall at
McDonald's so I decided to make this
fake poster of me and my friend it's now
been 51 days since that's that's such a
funny idea
our video seemed like what you can get
away with decorating so what are all
these animal interactions that this
subreddits so weird that's like a new
video game waiting to happen come on
each frog is alive no wait what calm
down calm down okay play dead it won't
be interested in dead body right please
go away stupid bear oh yeah
study shows rent can learn to drive tiny
cars and they find it relaxing he slaps
your mom what are you doing he replies
I'm not gonna slap anyone's mom I love
my mom to death and she would kill me if
I ever slapped that woman a picture of
me and my mom that is so if you enjoyed
the time you wasted then it's not waste
of time blessed advice just like
watching this video hope you guys
enjoyed smash like subscribe we are
doing suka be at merch
check out now present calm slash
PewDiePie very epic see you tomorrow bye
bye we're all excited about the new game
that's coming out and I can't wait to
play it it starts with the letter P can
you guess what it is
here with the pie pick ceiling of course
what you thought it was Pokemon dumbass
you stinky brainer
[Music]